-Thanks to newly developed
technology, we here at
"Late Night"
now have the ability
to record the tiny voice that is
inside Donald Trump's head.
And you might be surprised
to know that like everyone's
inner voice, Donald Trump's
is filled with paralyzing fear
and self-doubt.
So here it is once again,
the tiny voice in the back
of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
-Mr. President --
-[ As Trump ] Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in the back of your head,
and oh, yeah.
You are in
a minefield right now.
There are so many things
that could go wrong
in this situation.
Who looked at this guy's outfit
and said, "We should put him
in the same room
as Donald J. Trump
and a bunch of reporters"?
This is against every instinct
in your body,
to stand here, not grab
the microphone,
and point out everything that
is different about this person.
The hat, the robe, the beard --
Oh, my God.
You wanna say something
about the beard.
You're gonna go crazy.
When is this gonna be over?
Somebody get Dark Santa
outta here.
Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in the back of your head.
And I wanna remind you that
this is a medal ceremony,
but that medal is not for you.
So whatever you do,
don't take that medal.
Oh, but you
wanna take it so bad.
It's such a good medal.
You can't stop looking at it,
thinking about how pretty it
would look around your fat neck.
But hey, maybe someday
you'll get a medal.
You know what
you'd get a medal for?
Awkwardly swinging
your body side to side
while your dead arms hang limp
alongside your hulking mass.
-Something that we think
is very valuable.
-[ As Trump ] Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice in the back
of your head, and I'm here
to remind you that
you hate being President,
and you would give anything
right now to trade places
with this little kid in
his dad's lap to your right.
You have to pretend to listen
to this lady, and nod.
Meanwhile, he gets to play
with his dad's big old hand.
Looks like so much fun,
rocking back and forth.
And you have to sit still.
He probably gets to throw
a temper tantrum, too.
When he throws a temper tantrum
it's cute, but when you do it,
everyone on CNN says,
"Oh, he's a baby."
Oh no, he's going to yawn.
Oh, you want to yawn
so bad, and oh,
that lucky son of
a bitch is taking a nap.
Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in your head again,
and are you thinking
what I'm thinking?
Because it really seems like
your wife doesn't love you.
You know why I think that?
Because people who are in love
do not scowl for all 24 hours
of the day.
These people taking pictures are
gonna crack their iPhone screens
with how angry she looks
all the time.
Hey, what was the last
real conversation
you two had, anyway?
Because the last thing
I remember is election night,
when she turned to you and said,
"Are you happy now?"
Hey, by the way, who is
this guy talking right now?
And who is this woman who
is standing next to your wife?
What is going on?
You have no idea where
you are right now, do you?
No idea at all.
Oh, boy.
-Intellectual property rights.
-[ As Trump ] Hey, Donald.
It's me, the tiny voice
in the back
in your head and wow,
look at your Secretary
of Commerce, Wilbur Ross.
You thought you would get
to work with the coolest people
if you were President,
but look who is in your cabinet:
A very small man hovering around
the age of 112 who does not know
how to lower a microphone.
It looks like his eyeballs
are giving a speech.
And if his eyeballs were giving
a speech I bet they'd say,
"Somebody get us out
of this old-ass head."
No one is watching
this right now saying,
"Oh, I wish I could switch
places with Donald Trump,
and hang out with Wilbur Ross,
and Mike Pence."
Look what you've done
with your life.
You used to roll
with porn stars, and now
you're with Boresville
and Snoresville.
Sad.
Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in your head, and oh, boy.
The tiny table is out.
And you know what
the little table means --
it's time to sign your name.
But don't do it so big
that you run out of paper.
Oh, the big D.
And the O and the N
and the A and the --
Oh, you're running out of paper.
I hope you can fit it in.
Oh, you just made it.
And now, show everybody
how proud you are,
'cause you signed
a piece of paper.
This is the part
of the job you crush.
You're the best at this.
And now, put it away.
Oh, let's do another one.
Let's do another one.
Yep, pretend like you care
what it says.
Big D.
Little O, little N, little A.
little L, little D.
Big old T!
Don't run out of paper.
There we go.
♪♪♪♪